entreprises ont payé 10 milliards de
trop avec les intérêts le gouvernement
estime que c'est aux entreprises de pays
et d'une certaine façon
donc ça c'est le choix du gouvernement
moi je conteste ce choix mais c'est le
choix du gouvernement donc il invente
une nouvelle taxe probablement
d'augmenter l'impôt sur le sur les
sociétés et il le fait aussi dans la
précipitation puisqu'il ne fait pas en
étant de façon en conservant le rythme
de la procédure budgétaire ce qui est
tout à fait possible et d'inscrire ce
texte dans le collectif budgétaire de
fin d'année si tu as une précipitation a
répondu notre précipitations est